il porte encore les stigmates de la
révolution qui a bouleversé sa vie et
son pays
il y a dix ans mort scène a assisté à la
chute de celui qui a dirigé la libye
pendant 40 ans alors que des milliers
d'opposants défier l'armée de mouammar
kadhafi dans de nombreuses villes les
civils ne sont pas épargnés
c'est notamment le cas de mort scène
pris pour cible par les forces de
l'ancien guide libyen
une mitrailleuse utilisées par les
forces de kadhafi m'a touché j'ai été
blessé avec deux autres hommes l'un a
été blessé à la main l'autre au pied et
et ma blessure était à la colonne
vertébrale soigner en allemagne mort
scène est revenu en libye en 2019
il veut toujours croire dans un avenir
meilleur alors que le pays tente de
retrouver la stabilité depuis la mort de
moammar kadhafi en octobre 2011 la libye
s'est enlisé dans une guerre civile aux
multiples ramifications groupes tribaux
et djihadistes ont su profiter des
faiblesses d'un pouvoir politique
divisée entre deux autorités
d'une part le gouvernement d'union
nationale basée à tripoli est reconnu
par l'onu et d'autre part l'armée
nationale libyenne dirigé par le
maréchal rallye fav tard est basée à
tobrouk
chaque camp bénéficiant de l'appui de
pays aux intérêts divergents
ces turbulences ont durablement affaibli
l'économie d'un pays autrefois prospère
à commencer par la production pétrolière
elle a chuté de 90% en moins de dix ans
à cela s'ajoute une inflation galopante
et des pénuries d'essence d'électricité
de liquidités selon le ministère de
l'économie du gouvernement d'union
nationale les prix de la majorité des
produits de première nécessité ont
augmenté de plus de 50% en 2020 c'est
une récession sans précédent
sans stabilité aucune réforme ne sera
possible
les investisseurs étrangers ne
reviendrons pas sans garanties de
sécurité
malgré ce marasme économique et leur
sécurité un motif d'espoir est apparue
pour les rides
un dialogue politique a permis de
désigner un nouvel exécutif intérimaire
abdelhamid beiba sera chargé de conduire
le gouvernement jusqu'au prochaines
élections fixée à la fin de l'année